I mentioned last night when we were  having dinner that when you first got  the job as CEO you got a call from Steve  Jobs and he offered you some advice well  he didn't call to offer me advice but we  had worked together on a Nike Apple  collaboration called nike+ so we took  what Apple knows what Nike knows you  know brought a new technology to the  market anyway long story short he said  hey congratulations it's great you're  going to do a great job I said well do  you have any advice and he said no no  you're great and then there's a pause  and it goes well I do have some advice  because Nike makes some of the best  product in the world I mean product that  you lust after absolutely beautiful  stunning product but you also make a lot  of crap we said just get rid of the  crappy stuff and focus on the good stuff  and then I expected a little pause and a  laugh but there was there was a pause  but no laughs at the end and he was  absolutely right